Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode du Coup de Phil'.
Tiens d'ailleurs, pourquoi je dis "yo" ?
Et pourquoi je porte un tee-shirt avec une référence à Flash ?
Et puis, pourquoi je suis ici à vous parler de philosophie ?
Et pourquoi vous, ça vous intéresse ?
Toutes ces réponses se trouvent dans l'Habitus de Bourdieu.
Le fait de porter ce tee-shirt, ou ma manière de parler, mes goûts, mes avis,
tout ça c'est ce qui va me rendre unique en tant qu'être humain,
et je dirais même plus, en tant qu'être social,
c'est-à-dire par rapport à la société et aux relations avec les autres êtres humains.
Toutes ces choses là, comme ma gestuelle avec les mains,
c'est des choses que j'ai acquises durant ma socialisation.
Eh bien l'ensemble de ces éléments c'est ce que Pierre Bourdieu va appeler l'Habitus.
Pierre Bourdieu c'est un sociologue français né en 1930 et mort en 2003,
assez engagé et pas seulement sociologue puisqu'il s'était investi
par exemple dans l'indépendance de l'Algérie ou le soutien aux sans-papiers.
Il a aussi écrit énormément de livres sur la sociologie
tellement qu'il en a même sorti un sur le foot !
Si si ! Ça s'appelait "Les enjeux du football".
Il était au moins vivant pour voir la finale de 98 et ça, ça fait plaisir.
Si vous n'étiez pas encore nés en 98, c'est pas grave, vous vivrez plein d'autres trucs cools.
Et d'ailleurs tous ces trucs cools que vous vivrez
vont vous faire évoluer et vous façonner d'une certaine manière.
Une façon d'être : votre Habitus.
Et ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que cet Habitus il va se faire avec nos expériences
et donc aussi à l'aide de ce qui nous entoure.
Ça commence pendant l'enfance et l'adolescence, ce qu'on appelle la socialisation primaire,
c'est la famille, l'école, en fait c'est toute la première sphère
dans laquelle on va évoluer et avoir notre éducation, par exemple grâce au langage.
Et pas juste les mots, aussi le corps.
L'enfant va apprendre à dire "merci", il va apprendre comment le dire,
mais il va aussi apprendre à le dire par la gestuelle.
Il va apprendre à exprimer d'autres choses, comme ce qu'il veut manger,
mais aussi le sourire ou la grimace.
Tout ça, ça va construire l'enfant, et cette construction continue à l'âge adulte.
C'est la socialisation secondaire.
[voix off] Donc du coup, vous avez appris votre langage avec vos potes ?
Ouais.
[voix off] Et votre manière de bouger dans une école de danse contemporaine ?
C'est ça.
[voix off] Mais du coup vous êtes pas trop schizophrène ?
Schizo quoi ?
T'as dit quoi mon gars ?
J'vais t'éclater mon gars !
Donc c'est pour ça qu'un enfant né dans une classe ouvrière,
il n'aura pas la même éducation qu'un enfant né dans un milieu très aisé.
Un guitariste de rock s'habillera pas pareil qu'un chanteur de reggae
et un trader n'utilisera pas le même langage qu'un peintre.
Sauf sur l'expression "s'emmêler les pinceaux",
parce que c'est une expression qui est largement utilisée du coup ça dépasse le cadre de...
d'ailleurs quand je parle de cadre ça n'a rien à voir...
Ça dépasse le jargon du métier de peintre, quoi.
Genre il y a pas besoin de pinceau pour s'emmêler les pinceaux...
Juste une petite précision.
C'est pour ça que des individus placés dans des conditions similaires
ont sensiblement la même vision de la situation, la même notion de ce qu'on a le droit de faire ou non,
et les mêmes loisirs, façons de s'habiller ou de se comporter.
Leur Habitus est très proche car ils ont suivi des étapes de socialisation qui sont elles aussi très proches.
Par contre c'est pas parce qu'on est dans un même groupe social
que nos Habitus sont totalement identiques.
Chaque personne est confrontée dans sa vie à des expériences sociales différentes.
Par exemple dans un groupe de potes, on aura tendance à vouloir aller voir le même film,
mais on pensera pas tous forcément la même chose de ce film.
L'Habitus ne déclenche pas automatiquement des conduites identiques,
mais plutôt des tendances à certaines conduites.
Et heureusement, sinon on serait tous pareils.
Parce que l'Habitus au final, c'est ce qui façonne notre identité.
Nos goûts, notre vision des choses, notre manière de parler,
c'est des choses avec lesquelles on se définit.
[voix off] Vous aimez bien le thé vert ?
[tous] Ouais, ouais
[voix off] Et vous aimez bien Call of Duty ?
[tous] Non, ah non...
[voix off] Et est-ce que vous aimez bien Jul ?
[les 3 à gauches] Oh pitié non ! Jul, c'est nul un peu... [celui à droite] Bah si c'est pas si mal Jul quand même...
[celui à gauche] Enlève ce couvre-chef mec.
Tu mérites pas de faire partie du groupe social des casquettes rouges.
Donc l'Habitus, c'est ultra important, c'est comme ça qu'on va se définir,
mais c'est aussi comme ça qu'on va se définir par rapport aux autres.
Il va nous donner notre place dans la société,
puisque avec lui on va faire partie d'un groupe donné qui sera plus ou moins séparé des autres groupes.
Ça c'est ce qu'on vient de voir, mais peut-être encore plus important,
c'est qu'un certain Habitus aura tendance à entraîner un certain Habitus.
Bourdieu nous dit que l'Habitus, c'est
des "structures structurées prédisposées à fonctionner comme structures structurantes".
"structure structurée" on l'a vu, c'est structurée par notre construction sociale,
mais c'est aussi une "structure structurante".
Ça veut dire que notre Habitus il ne sera plus une conséquence, ce sera aussi une cause.
Si vous vous retrouvez face à une attaque de zombies par exemple.
Vous pourrez pas reproduire des mécanismes de pensée identiques à ceux qui sont dans votre Habitus
parce que c'est une situation à laquelle vous n'avez jamais fait face
et vous n'avez pas été construit avec ça.
J'vais vous éclater les zombies !
Toi aussi là-bas !
Par contre, tout ce que vous allez faire à partir de l'instant où vous êtes dans cette nouvelle situation,
ça découle de vos expériences passées.
Et donc c'est donc votre Habitus que vous allez prendre les codes sociaux
que vous allez adapter à cette nouvelle situation.
"structure structurante"
Je vous laisserai faire les connexions avec le déterminisme de Spinoza, tout ça tout ça...
Par contre il y a une question qui se pose :
Est-ce que cette structure de mon Habitus je vais la garder toute ma vie ?
Pour Bourdieu oui, c'est ce qu'il appelle l'hystérésis de l'Habitus.
*boughroughouahouh*
Non, on a dit hystérésis, pas hystérie.
Ah ! Parce que.. Ah ouais, c'est pas... c'est pas pareil...
Et il utilise l'exemple de Don Quijote, Don Quichotte, pour illustrer ce concept.
Don Quichotte c'est un chevalier,
il a le mode de pensée d'un chevalier, le comportement, le langage, l’attitude d'un chevalier,
sauf que c'est un monde où il n'y a plus de chevalerie.
Donc il est inadapté à l'environnement dans lequel il se trouve,
mais son Habitus est si fort qu'il va pas se résigner
et il est tellement à fond qu'il va s'attaquer aux moulins à vent qu'il prend pour de grands tyrans.
Et globalement c'est pour ça que les évolutions de nos mœurs sont si difficiles :
parce que certains Habitus continuent de perdurer à une époque où ils perdent de leur sens.
En tout cas voilà, moi ma façon d'être évolue plutôt, je suis assez content,
j'ai même pas fait de jeu de mot avec par exemple,
Bourdieu et son Ha... bite !
Prend l'Habitus de passer le Coup de Phil' à un anus, et de t'abonner à Cyrus,
ça lui fait un gros bonus.
J'espère que ça t'a plus, je vous envoie du love et de la puce !
*yalus*